It is great to welcome back to the program
today.
Dr. Christopher DeCarlo, who's an award winning
philosopher, educator and author of the latest
book on critical thinking called So You Think
You Can Think Tools for Having Intelligent
Conversations and Getting Along.
It's great to have you back on.
Good to be here.
Always a pleasure.
So a common question I get from viewers when
I take live calls is I have family members
who believe this or who believe that.
And I want to know how it is that I should
confront them.
And usually my answer is that depends on how
willing you are to ruin the relationship.
In other words, there's ways to do this more
lightly with a Socratic method of questioning
and sort of gentle inquiry into how one formed
their beliefs.
There's ways to have these conversations much
more pointedly and aggressively.
Give me your sort of 30000 foot view on how
some of these often difficult conversations
can be approached.
Right.
So in this book, I talk about spectral discussions.
And what I mean by that is if an issue can
be polarized and many of them are polarized,
I take, for example, gun control, something
to which your country deals with on a daily
basis.
You know, what you do is you look at the extremes
of that.
What what should we do?
Well, allow all guns everywhere, no matter
what.
You can drive a tank to work.
You know, you can do all of that kind of stuff.
The other end of the spectrum, no guns whatsoever.
You know, all that kind of thing.
And then start by determining where on the
spectrum the two discussants lie, like, where
are you?
And then see how how polarized those views
are.
And then try to imagine, is there any common
area between those two positions and what
are those?
So, you know, start with what is your argument?
What is it that you believe?
Allow me to understand that.
Have each other say what their arguments are
back to each other.
We call it Steel Manning.
You're probably familiar with this.
Yeah.
Rather than Straw manning the other person's
argument and making a mockery.
You really want to say.
OK.
So let me get this straight.
Is this what you believe?
And then you lay it on the line, then they
can do the same.
Now you know where you are on that spectrum.
And now you can talk about, you know, would
we be able to change our views?
Is there any evidence or any information that
might draws closer together?
So I'm finding that this method is becoming
very helpful.
Yes.
Peter Bogosian has described that.
What would cause you to change your mind if
it were the case?
The feasibility tests to see if someone is
even open to to reexamining their their beliefs.
Now, when it comes to I mean, to pick something
that has come up recently here in the United
States.
And by the way, so Christopher's Canadian
and that's why he said your country.
And just so people understand the context
here of the discussion here in the United
States.
There's a big controversy now around statues,
Confederate era statues and statues reminiscent
of slavery.
And one of the critiques I had of a lot of
the conversations that are happening are that
the conversations in media are often only
represented by extreme views, meaning you
should never take a statue down.
And on the other hand, take down George Washington
because he owns like these extremes, whereas
most people probably would be able to have
a more nuanced conversation, like, well, listen,
there was an era where everybody had slaves.
And what we should look at is maybe more whether
the individual is known for promoting slavery
versus whether they're really right.
So that that seems to be a big part of the
conversation, that often the conversations
are only happening in extremes.
Yeah, and it's unfortunate, right.
That and the media is partially to blame because
they love the extremes.
Right.
You've got a great story.
You get more clicks, you get more hits, you
get more viewers, whatever it is.
You know, we we were fascinated with the confrontation,
as it were.
We've lost the capacity to appreciate nuance.
And it looks like we're in a baby out with
the bathwater kind of movement right now where,
you know, no matter what good a person has
done in their life, if during those times
they were involved in other types of activities
which are now deemed quite reprehensible or
horrific or horrible or whatever it is, then
everything that that person might have accomplished
that was good is ignored because they were
involved with these other kind of nefarious
or or questionable.
Types of moral activities, and we need to
have the conversation around these statues
to look at them and say, you know what good,
if any, has.
Has this person done for humanity and what
are the bad things and use it to use these
as teachable moments.
And if if they if they are indeed offensive,
for whatever reasons, should we just put them
in museums then and then use them as for educational
purposes to say, yes, this person did X, Y
and Z.
But you know what?
They also did this as well.
You know, I teach at Ryerson University.
Edgerton Ryerson was responsible for the the
school systems that put a lot of Aboriginal
kids, took them away from their parents and
put them in these schools what what's called
the residential school problem.
But his statue is still standing at Ryerson
University.
I'm wondering if it's just a matter of time
before, you know, people think, you know,
that's got to come down as well.
So he did a lot of great things for education,
but he also did some not so great things.
It's the world is more complicated if if we
hold our heroes, you know, those in high esteem
too high, they have that much further to fall
when we realize nobody's perfect.
And, you know, we are a new monts, difficult
species at best here in the United States.
We are experiencing the deadly repercussions.
I don't think that's an exaggeration of a
critical thinking gap or lack when it comes
to coronavirus.
And this applies to understanding how masks
work.
This comes to ideas like if we tested less,
we'd have fewer cases.
I mean, there's no shortage of sort of examples.
What do you make of the way in which this
is failing in the United States?
Is it education?
Is it culture?
Is it's economics?
I mean, like, where do we start?
Yeah.
There are so many systems involved here.
Right.
And some of the work I'm doing in critical
thinking is something I call relational systemic,
which is to look at all the systems that are
involved that interplay and cause people to
think the way they do at a given time in history.
Yeah, we can look at the education systems
for sure.
But you've got to understand, you know, Meems
can kill you.
I mean, I've written about, you know, memetic
equilibrium and the idea that when you get
comfortable with a set of ideas, it doesn't
matter if they run counter to reality.
You know, if ideology can outweigh reality.
And in so doing, you mentioned that weaponized
ignorance.
You you talk about the idea that the mask
has become a symbol of oppression in your
country for some people.
And that is absolutely bizarre for the rest
of the world to look at that and think you're
missing a really important point here.
And that is this is a public health issue.
It's not as it's apolitical.
It has nothing to do with politics.
We want everybody to survive.
We don't care what your politics is.
We don't want you to die.
We don't want you to feel discomfort or to
spread the disease any further.
So, you know, that is a horrific example of
weaponized ignorance and using it as a tool
or a symbolic representation of a political
movement.
So some people in my audience feel very strongly,
and I've even said this before, that if critical
thinking and epistemology and philosophy were
a part of everybody's schooling, starting
probably around seventh grade, age 12, that
a lot of this that we're seeing would be short
circuited and preempted altogether.
But then I do get pushback from people who
maybe people who work in school systems that
are teaching these things to some degree,
saying the problem is bigger than that.
And you have to understand that teachers can
only do so much anyway.
And a lot of it is what's going on at home
and what's going on in culture and what's
going on in the media.
So what's the lowest hanging fruit?
Where do we start to turn this around?
And what could have the best the biggest effect
most quickly?
Right.
I I've been lobbying governments here in Canada
and have had some success with trying to get
critical thinking taught at first of all at
the high school system.
You know very well, David.
That critical thinking teaches people how
to think right.
It's the tools that allow them to better understand
information and then to determine the acceptability
of that information and whether or not they
should act on that information.
And I do very much believe if we can get critical
thinking into the schools as early as possible,
I believe seven and eight is probably the
right time to start to introduce it, to get
it going.
I think we'd be much more difficult for people
to then say, I don't care what science says.
You know, my leader maintains X. Yes, he cuts
it empowers people.
Critical thinking isn't just something you
do.
It's what you live.
And we have to make that a part of people's
lives so that it becomes almost reflexive.
It almost becomes a reflex action when information
is is presented in a particular way that is
false to the way in which the natural world
actually functions.
And that's where we need to start.
We need to start at those those middle age
grades, seven and eight and all the way through
high school for sure.
From from the standpoint of the virus and
what you've observed, what if we do a sort
of analysis, analysis of fallacious thinking
or fallacious assertions?
What are the main fallacies that you're seeing
in the context of discussions about cases,
viral spread, contagion, treatment masks,
et cetera?
I mean, just get you know, if you have a couple
bullet points on that, right?
Well, first of all, it's the it's the misinformation
and disinformation we have to stop.
And that's, you know, at what was a twains
that a lie can make its self around the world,
you know, halfway around the world while the
truth is putting its shoes on or whatever.
So once ments misinformation gets out there,
we need to focus on how to combat that quickly
and effectively.
And to me, there's no easy solution for that.
Social media has gotten to the point where
influencers are being trusted more than, you
know, scientists.
Yes.
And right.
Once we get to to that level, then I think
it it it becomes paramount that science and
the influencers, if possible, the scientists
and the influencers could somehow work together.
Right.
What's horrifying about that is some attempts
were made like, for example, Dr. Foushee did
a bunch of live streams with folks like Stephan
Curry, the NBA basketball player, and trying
to sort of break it.
It's just a I don't know if it was too little
or too late, but you've got, you know, a political
movement which is listening more to a game
show host than an infectious disease doctor.
I know.
I just don't know.
It's it just feels like we're living in an
alien's thought experiment.
It just seems so weird.
What what what's happening.
Right.
To to see this occur and to know what the
truth is.
And I'm not talking.
I'm a big tree, big t metaphysical truth or
anything.
I'm just talking about scientific probabilistic
truth.
That is for the benefit of all humankind.
And I really I'm at a loss with this one in
terms of what's the best way to engage in
having the conversation, like how much evidence
can be provided in order to convince somebody
that they really ought to wear a mask.
Right.
That it's not a political statement that,
you know, finally Trump wore one for the first
time.
I think, you know, the other day, what was
he at Walter Reed or wherever?
Yeah.
You know, it was they basically said you're
wearing one.
So that that's good.
Somebody's got to stand up to this guy.
Like, I don't know why people aren't, but
maybe that's just the cult of personality
that he has.
All right.
When it comes to statistics, it's of course,
we know very much about how statistics can
be shaped in order to give a the impression
of A or the opposite of a.
And a lot of it is just understanding the
mechanisms that are used.
What specifically can you recommend to the
audience in order to parse statistics for
themselves, like when Donald Trump says we're
testing more than anyone or the death rate
has to come down tenfold?
Is this a mathematical understanding that
people need?
Or is it more of a critical thinking, understanding?
Both.
Like I really do think statistical and probabilistic
reasoning is a part of critical thinking,
and it should be taught fairly early on.
And I'm actually dealing with teachers right
now who have who are, you know, creatively
using the pandemic to teach students about
statistics and probability.
It's a wonderful teachable moment that they're
using under such hard conditions.
It's you know, it's like, you know, the flower
emerging out of, you know, the manure kind
of thing.
It's wonderful to see them take.
This as a teachable moment that they can then
say, look, you know, as I say, this is a numbers
game.
This comes down to numbers.
And the better numbers we have, the more accurate
we can be with those numbers.
Testing, tracing, tracking.
Knowing who has it.
Knowing who doesn't have it.
Look, until there's a vaccine.
This is what we've got.
This is our defense, especially with a virus
that has, you know, such a large, asymptomatic
population.
And that's really what we're dealing with
here.
And nobody really wants to address that.
But the fact of the matter is we can solve
a lot of the issues if it's done intelligently
and if we have the right numbers.
But we have to be together on this in the
United States.
If you look at county data, you see that the
growth rates of cases are significantly higher
in counties that voted for Donald Trump relative
to counties that voted for Hillary Clinton.
But if we step back from from that, maybe
so specifically in your work, have there been
certain groups that seem to do better when
it comes to critical thinking than worse?
And I'm not talking about genetically or anything
like that, but through cultural and education
reasons, whether it's Democrats versus Republicans
or religious versus non-religious or whatever
the case may be.
Are there trends you've observed?
That's a great question.
You know, I mean, we we have seen that those
who are more fervently religious have a little
bit more difficult time reconciling inconsistencies
with their world views.
But that's to be expected.
Right.
You know, my my take on religion is basically,
you know, you can believe in anything you
want.
You just can't harm people through those beliefs
or harm other species through those beliefs.
So if you're so dogmatic, you've reached a
point where you refuse to entertain the possibility
that you could be wrong.
You see the obvious danger in that.
And there's when I look at someone like Donald
Trump, there is nothing more dangerous than
blind ignorance, which is not even knowing.
You don't know like that's a really dangerous
epistemic state of mind to be in.
And I see it continuously.
And so, yeah, if a person is overly dogmatic,
that's obviously going to present barriers.
Right.
And then you have to adjust your strategy
for having a conversation with that person.
You have to be much more Socratic, much more
gentle in your approach, because the harder
you try to consider or analyze their beliefs,
the more they're going to dig in and say,
you're the problem, not me.
What do you think will be the long term effect
on society of of the virus?
I had a conversation with Brian Greene not
long ago, and there's sometimes this instinct
that this is really going to change things,
period.
And public health is going to be done differently.
The way people greet each other is going to
change permanently.
I tend to go in the direction of things, sort
of return to the mean, and people go back
to normal.
And and it's very hard to get really long
lasting change for for humans.
Where are you on that issue?
I'm hopeful.
You know, I'm cautiously optimistic.
But let's face it, David.
My colleagues and I have been writing to our
politicians and to politicians in China for
over two decades, basically saying, look,
there's going to be a pandemic if we don't
put initiatives in place that monitor the
sale of certain types of species of animals.
It's just it was just a ticking time bomb.
It was not a matter of if, but when.
And, you know, a lot of them would come back
and say, well, we caught Serzh.
You know, we took care of Meurs, we got H1
and we've got a vaccine for H1N1.
We're doing a good job.
And my colleagues and I were saying, yeah,
until we get either a long incubation period
or people who are asymptomatic or both, and
then you're not going to be ready.
And they didn't listen to that.
So I'm very hopeful that in the future we
are able to develop worldwide policies for
other countries in terms of how things are
done.
And this is not to, you know, necessarily
be a, you know, critical of other cultures
for their lifestyles and whatnot.
No, this is really just a world public health
issue.
These are just the facts, just facts of bats.
And we know bats contain a lot of viruses
and they do jump to other species, which then
can jump to humans.
We need to take the science and we need to
utilize that as best as we can to make sure
this doesn't happen again.
Or if it does, we've got measures in place
that will will stop it very, very quickly
and not allow this to occur.
Now, that's hopeful for the future in regards
to your other questions.
I think early on after people start to get
vaccinated, it's going to take a little while
for people to just start some anyhow to handshake
or to, you know, congregate in groups or whatnot.
It's going to be interesting.
Is it going to make a world of germophobia?
I hope not.
I want people to be germ aware.
We need to be smart about pathogens.
And and I'm very hopeful that you're you're
in the Boston area where they filmed Jaws.
You're probably too young to remember this,
but when Jaws came out, there was a huge influx
of students taking marine biology.
All right.
They were majoring in marine biology.
When in, you know, Indiana Jones came out,
there was a huge influx of students taking
archeology.
I'm hoping after this is a huge influx of
people going into microbial ecology, which
is exactly what we need.
We need people to understand the interconnectedness
of the very tiny pathogens to the rest of
the world.
It's really an arms race between us and pathogens.
And this was a virus, a relatively weak virus.
You know, this was I'm not gonna say easy,
but it could have been much worse.
Oh, my goodness.
This could have been, you know, imagine if
this were like an Ebola, right?
It would be horrific.
It would be a black death time.
It would be not a good time for this planet.
The book is.
So you think you can think tools for having
intelligent conversations and getting along?
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Dr Christopher DeCarlo.
So great to have you on.
I appreciate your time once again.
My pleasure.